ariana grande and her rumoured beau Mac  Miller get new tattoos re to snapchat on  Thursday to debut her new age she also  got the Venus symbol tatted on another  finger describing the tats on Instagram  as so fine and perfectly fatigued she  thanked her tattoo artist dr Woo who  also inked her rumored new man 24 year  old Mac Miller the rapper joined re at  the shamrock social club and added a pic  of a horizon to his collection of  tattoos the pair were recently spotted  kissing while on a sushi date around LA  but met two years ago while  collaborating on re song the way re set  to perform her collab side-by-side with  Nicki Minaj at the VMAs on Sunday  you